the hijab 10
discount code for 10 discount on a wide
range of products including premium
ethiopian black seed products
okay okay we're good go ahead uh
um so
did you grow up in london and also
i mean what level of religious would you
say that you are
well i think i'm i'm an observant
orthodox traditionalist muslim um sunday
and
kind of uh orientation if you wanna put
it that way and um yes i
i grew up not really in that i mean i
grew up in a liberal environment i grew
up here in london um i went to a
multicultural school
um actually went to the same school as
some very famous uh people who went to
syria
and
which i will not kind of famous
yeah not in the positive sense and um
and i've seen everything you know and
i've engaged with everyone it's really a
privileged experience i think when you
grow up in a multi deeply multicultural
society and you see people from
different perspectives and different
backgrounds and you can get along with
them you you learn how to kind of be
what you are be proud of what you are by
the same time learn to disagree with
people and still get along with them
this is a very important thing and being
in a multicultural society all my life i
think that's been probably one of the
biggest takeaways
yeah i mean i i couldn't agree more i
think being in a multicultural society
forces you to understand that there are
a multitude of perspectives and you need
to kind of find like a middle ground
between what all of you think and try
and work out what is a way that you can
find harmony in terms of interacting
with these other groups and all find out
your positive aspects exactly um
within that diversity when you're
growing up were there many jewish people
that you knew
yes i actually live in the jewish area
which area did you grow up in uh saint
johnswood
so yeah
i've lived there for 20 years
um
so i've lived in this of course we have
jewish neighbors we have people that are
jewish people that went to my school
jewish people that you know i grew up
with i knew the rabbis and then the
synagogues and so on yeah we have one of
the biggest and most important
synagogues in the vicinity so in the
area so yeah absolutely
and of course what i realized about um
jewish people is that they're very
similar to the muslim community and so
much as it's we think
that jewish people have a uniformity of
opinions but they don't there are
liberal jews there are you know there
are orthodox jews and within the
orthodox spectrum you have heredi you
have you know
so on and so forth it really it
subcompartmentalizes it and it
you know this category of the category
and so it's not a monolithic entity this
is a very important thing i think people
need to understand when when discussing
jewish people because it's not a
monastic entity and that's what i've
discovered really quickly it was
something that growing up i didn't
understand but now i'm fully aware of
well people i think people lose that
nuance generally there is almost no
monolithic group out there there's a
spectrum within every single group and
it's much easier for people to
generalize and then make a sweeping
statement on the basis of that
generalization which i think can most
often be problematic and you've got to
look for the nuance and things
absolutely but when you say you were
growing up and you didn't know that what
was your what was your perception of
judaism when you were growing up before
you educated yourself what did you think
about jesus what did you know about jews
well to be honest with you judaism as a
religion we always knew was one of the
closest religions to the religion of
islam obviously we have to we have to
delineate jewishness into two
sub-compartments you've got the ethnic
component and you've got the religious
component
but if we're talking about the religious
component then it's we've always known
that judaism stands as one of the
closest religions to the religion of
islam because both religions are you
know uncompromisingly monotheistic right
there's only one god worthy of worship
both religions speak about abraham
obviously and all the prophets like noah
and all this kind of thing in the bible
in the quran and the old testament or
the hebrew hebrew bible as the
jews or jewish clergy prefer
and
and obviously both religions believe in
the ten commandments and moses uh moses
as well which to muslims is one of the
most mighty messengers most most
important men
of human kind in fact he's mentioned the
quran more than muhammad is he's
mentioned in the quran more than any
other prophet he's mentioned he's
mentioned 70 times by name in the quran
and so
the stories of the quran will be very
much
similar
to the stories in the old testament
however with one i would say
key difference the key difference being
where in the old testament there is
you could
kind of summarize the main message being
let my people go right the quran doesn't
state that that's the main thing the
quran states that when moses came to the
people of israel that the main thing was
he was trying to get them to believe
pharaoh himself to believe and it wasn't
about let my people go it's about
believe in one god and save yourself
it wasn't an exclusive discourse for a
tribe or something let my people go like
no there was that as well let my people
go yes but the most important thing is
believe in one god and worship him and
that's something that runs through all
the stories of the quran
but to kind of answer your question
we've always known that the proximity
between kind of judaism as religion and
islam on the on the fundamentals is
quite close and
that there are many things in terms of
our practices
like
orthodox jewish practice
eating pork
or obviously lack thereof
we can eat kosher food we used to
actually grow up on kosher meat because
it was much more well actually maybe you
shouldn't say this but
better quality than the alternative
right
so things like that yeah i can't i can't
say um and so you know
things like that we were aware of but
clearly as well
there's an aspect of politics
but to be honest in my household there
was always a distinction that was made
between
zionism as a political ideology
and judaism as a religion
and so
i've always known that even since i was
young but once again i didn't know the
sub compartments and the
the the extent of diversity until i got
a bit older so was israel something that
was discussed in your household growing
up yes no doubt about it
i'm egyptian by you know i'm background
obviously i'm a british egyptian and so
the wars you know the 48 war the 60 66
67 war um and obviously 73 one
particular 73 was was is hailed in egypt
as a great victory for egypt
uh obviously what we know about that was
that as sadat actually he politically
compromised
okay and it's interesting to note that
in egyptian culture this is seen as one
of the great
victories even though it was predicated
on a negotiation
so which is actually in many ways is
something good to think about because
that is to say that
people
want peace in the arab world people want
peace in the muslim world they don't
want to be in perpetual conflict with
their jewish neighbor
um or their israeli neighbor and or
there is never so
that is something that definitely was
there when i went to egypt you know we
have bridges that are named october or
the 6th of 6th of october bridge in
commemoration yeah yeah things like that
you know so that was definitely part of
the culture so growing up
it was a staple part of the culture and
uh israel seemed sort of a boogie man
kind of
it was you know i mean to be honest with
you right
when i was growing up
the the kind of internal conflicts
within egypt
started to override the discourse
and
you know
that was overshadowing eclipsing the
issue the historical issues if i grew up
in the 80s or the 70s i think the
situation would have been a little bit
different yeah
that's true i mean and so
from your perspective
how does
the discussion around israel affect
how people think about jewish people do
you think it does have an effect on how
people think about jewish people i think
really this is a sociological question
if we're being completely honest it's
like whether it does or not is it can be
a historical question um in terms of if
we look at the broad kind of stroke
situation from 1945 onward or 1948 to be
completely
precise the establishment of the state
of israel and how the arab nations
kind of reacted to that um how muslim
nations reacted to that um
it's gonna be a very difficult case for
someone to suggest that there was no
level of anti-semitism
that um that emerged in the in the
arable muslim world
as a result of the establishment of the
state of israel
um i i do think that to be honest with
you if you're looking at a broad stroke
historical perspective
that this this kind of anti-semitism is
very particular it's not it's not an
anti-semitism that existed in
spain where you know scholars talk about
lack of aventia or you know the idea of
a mutual coexistence between jews
muslims and christians or even the
ottoman empire i think it's particularly
pernicious and and i think it's
particularly outrageous actually because
it is now mixed it
effectively mixed um political discourse
with with religious schools in a way
that didn't exist in the past i think
that can be said historically but in
terms of
if you're talking about the uk discourse
in the uk kind of like life and so on
it's that requires kind of sociological
research and and to be fair
the kind of studies that we have so far
on jewish communities and muslim
communities
it's difficult for me to make a comment
about that but what should be the case
is i think it's wholly important to
distinguish between jewishness and pr
and and being an israeli supporter or
being a zionist and if if if we don't
make this distinction i think there will
be some real problems that can emerge
well
sorry to refer to you directly ali
i mean in the video which i think you
were also included in isn't the title of
your video muslims confront radical
israelis
yes and isn't that doing exactly what
you're saying
shouldn't be done conflating a group of
jewish people in britain
and calling them israelis isn't that
doing exactly what you're saying you
shouldn't i mean if someone identifies
as an israeli supporter an apologist or
a pro-zionist right then they have
already shown their cards
what we're saying is that there is a
difference
between
israeli discourse or pro-israeli
discourse when we say that we mean those
who are sympathetic or apologetic
to the policies of the israeli
government policies which have seen the
death of 166 civilians recently of which
66 of them were were children
these policies the policies of blockade
the policies of settlement in the in the
west bank in sheikh
in these things if someone if we decide
to to oppose these policies okay that
should never be conflated with
anti-jewish and i think the reason why
is very clear
that
if we do that that will render those pro
anti-zionist those anti-zionist jews as
impossible subjects that are engaged in
a perpetual
self flagration of some sort self
treachery self hate of some sort they
become an impossible subject but we know
these people exist in fact according to
the definition of the british government
which uh on anti-semitism which was
published in 2016
one of the
definitions of anti-semitism is when you
hold jewish people responsible for the
actions of the israeli government and i
think doing the
doing that conflation
um puts that risk
of people
being anti-semitic and so it's very
important that if someone is an
apologist for for israel or for zionism
that that should be outlined and
delineated or otherwise completely
separated
from
a jewishness i think it's very important
i completely agree with you to be honest
on almost every single point do you not
think the title of that video for
example and
i mean maybe i don't want to get into it
in this way but can you can you first of
all tell me can you tell me what it was
that you did on golden screen and what
made you feel compelled to go and do
that when we went to stanford hill and
golden screen um
we were looking for our allies and
associates because we have many allies
pro
palestine anti-zionist allies and
associates uh many of which are on the
record with us holding hands in placards
and so on and
showing their disdain for the the
policies of the israeli government
and i think it's very important to give
these people a voice because it does
exactly what we're talking about in the
beginning it gives diversity to the
jewish community the jewish community
are not a monolith and there are a
significant sizable chunk of the jewish
community who see no connection
whatsoever with being jewish
and
um and support for israel in fact this
was published in
in one of the only studies that was done
in 2010
um
i think yes 2010 where about 4 000 jews
were questioned and a sizable population
saw no necessarily in control of jewish
people between support for israel and
jewishness this is these are not my
words the these are the sociological
findings of the jewish
policy the institute for jewish policy
uh in 2008. so i think here once again
it's it's imperative especially where
maybe right-wing media you know
organizations and so on
are reluctant to do so even to be honest
centrist uh media streams are reluctant
to do so that we give voice to these
voiceless pro-palestinian jewish people
who represent a big part of the jewish
community but can you literally in
layman's terms can you explain to me
what it was that you guys went out and
did that day just so we can right so
yeah what we did was we went to uh our
rabbi friends we went to many of our
associates from the jewish community to
condemn the actions of the israeli
government at that time which were
killing
indiscriminately killing civilian
populations in gaza they were in
description they were dropping bombs
on houses killing people
66 of them are children actually and we
thought that that was disgusting and to
be fair
we did unfortunately confront some
people which we were ready to confront
had you organized it with the rabbis to
go
to go down there and so i'm yeah so you
went down to golden screen and stanford
tales this was a day of this was a day
of where there was protest so it was
already organized everything was already
organized by organizers and those rabbis
by the way they are part of a panel of
ours and they they are part of the
decision carter
are these the nature carter rabbis is
that right yep that is nice yeah yeah so
yeah so you drove to
golden so you went straight from one to
the other yeah we went we went to about
10 different locations that day and was
that all with the the van which was i
think was it projecting yeah
pictures of the couple this station this
van is not just to be clear this van is
not our van it's not it's not we don't
own that van
this van and the pictures once again the
pictures of that van were chosen by a
panel of people
of which those
pro-palestinian um anti-zionist jews
were part of that panel and and some of
the the imagery of that van
we we objected to it we said we don't
really i think this is quite
antagonistic but they said look this is
the kind of thing we're seeing in the
academic discourse norman frenkelstein
himself wrote a book called the
holocaust industry and it's important
they said that we remind jews this was
their case
that we remind jews that we don't want
to fall we don't want to be the victim
of our own
past
we said if if you feel strongly about
that we cannot stop you from
expressing joy
not drove the van we have they had a
driver or something they organized they
organized oh absolutely this is not a
van in any way shape or form but we but
this was there was a panel of people of
which they were part of that panel and
they decided on the pictures and we we
spoke about it we were a little bit you
know a bit worried about the kind of
imagery in the country but but they said
yeah
this should be said in that in that
language in that strong language so
because this is our view the view is
that we have suffered one of the most
catastrophic and monstrous and
condemnable and abominable things in
human history
which is the holocaust
and we should have we we should teach
our upcoming generations
that we cannot even go anywhere near
doing that to another population not to
say that there is some kind of
comparison there is not but having said
that they said there is no comparison in
the size and scale of the obviously but
we don't even want to come close to that
with a barge point when you weren't you
worried about
it being antagonistic shouldn't you have
told them really to not come because if
there's no comparison there's a risk if
you're doing if you're doing it in front
of their van showing those images that
people might misconstrue and feel that
you are making a difference
there is a risk of course there is a
risk but the thing is i don't think that
pro zionist uh or apology people that
are apologetic to the the israeli
narrative
or the israeli government in fact that
those individuals should be protected
i i think that if they are willing
enough
and brave enough
to scrutinize or or to defend i should
say to defend their government's
policies or the government that they
support the policies they should be
brave enough to be cross-examined
scrutinized or otherwise interrogated
publicly as well and i think what it is
is that we've got to remember that in
israel there was um the status law in
which which categorically states and
it's still part of the books uh the
legislative books which categorically
states that israel is the creation
of the jewish people all the jewish
people but this again monolithic kind of
narrative um doesn't doesn't
give flavor to the jewish community
there's no diversity there
this is the problem narrative and what
we're saying is that there are some jews
out there as you know and i know that
will will condemn
israel with all vehemency and all vigor
and they will condemn them in language
which may be antagonistic to me and you
or me
particularly because i'm non-jewish but
i say give them a voice because they
deserve a voice and they've been blocked
by members of their own community not
all members but some members some
intolerant members of the wrong
community we all have them
from having that voice we will provide
the voice for them and what was the
reaction that you got to publishing that
video
well we got some we got a mixed reaction
we've got some people saying this was
exceptionally
well done and it was needed and this is
the kind of thing we need and we're
ruffling the feathers as part public
discourse and as part of freedom of
speech and expression and so on
and we have some people saying this is
antagonism this is uh stirring um you
know
division and so on
and this is the nature of public
discourse i think if we're going to have
any discussion whatsoever if it doesn't
accumulate or generate some kind of
controversy usually we're talking about
some mundane issue which
which which maybe
isn't worth talking about in the first
place but if this is one of the uh one
of the pieces of collateral damage that
you get from doing
freedom of speech properly
but as someone i mean so much of what
you're saying i agree with and i think
one of the things you clearly are
passionate about promoting is a sense of
harmony yes does it how does it make you
feel then that literally direct
accusations of anti-semitism were laid
at your door on the basis of what
yeah i i think they were saying that i
was stoking it
but what we this is once again you have
to appreciate that there are some people
um that conflate anti-israel israelis if
you want to call that or anti-zionism
without semitism we're saying that that
conflation itself is anthemic according
to the british definition of
british governmental definition
the british government itself has laid
down a definition which has been
accepted by a bulk of the bulk of
organizations in the in the west jewish
organizations which is that to equate
the government's actions the israeli
government's actions with jewish people
is anti-semitism they're telling me that
uh in fact if what you do is you attack
the israeli government and you attack
the policies the discriminatory policies
and the attacking policies of israeli
government then you're anti-semitic
we're saying that you're more likely to
fit the the category of anti-semitic
according to the british government
because you're making the conflation
is it not
implicitly accusatory
going to an area with a large jewish
community with the backdrop which which
wasn't the backdrop that you guys had
decided to bring
and going there and confronting people
isn't that isn't it i mean it's subtle
but isn't that implicitly implicitly
quite
i'll tell you i'll tell you what it's
like
i'll tell you what it's like
it's
the human rights watch have categorized
israel as an apartheid state you know
that it's on the public record and not
just them many different organizations
which are nothing to do with islam or
muslim or muslim community
now how i and you may be been around at
the time of the south african apartheid
and there was a white south african
community in britain and london
and had i gone with my cameras and said
i want to rally support against
apartheid from these people
if they were to say this is anti or
racial towards anti-south uh south
africans i would say that itself
is an affront to freedom of speech and
to freedom in general because if i'm
against an apartheid system and i want
to i want to rally support and get
associates from the community which are
probably most powerful and be being able
to make a case that if that is
anti-semitism then they have distorted
and defamed
or even
completely destroyed what it means to be
anti-semitic
what we have to go back to are robust
definitions which don't violate the
terms
anti-semitic is when you have certain
attitudes towards jewish people and
there's a whole definition that you can
find in the british government website
it's nothing to do
with someone being critical of israel or
going to any area in london which
doesn't belong to any community by the
way because it's a free country going to
any area in london and rallying support
from any member of any community and
that includes the muslim community the
black community the hispanic community
or any other community if i go to those
communities and i ask them listen we
have a cause and it's a pro-palestinian
course it's an anti-israel government
cause
would you like to join this cause
i have a full right to do that and i
think it's totally legitimate for any
community
is it is there not a risk i mean
lots of
debates get
brought down by associations with things
that they don't want to be associated
with didn't you run the risk of doing
that i'm mainly thinking of the van
because if you're going there and you're
confronting people with images and you
can make an assumption that a lot of the
people in that area will have had family
who
perished in the holocaust
you are associating yourself with
that van just by virtue of being
alongside it isn't that wasn't that
problematic did that not put you off
wanting to do it or did you not want to
draw a line and say the the van itself
is not my property it's got nothing to
do with me and the pictures on the van
as i said were were chosen by jewish
people now if jewish people want to talk
about the holocaust they can talk about
the holy ghost if black people want to
use the n word they can use the animal
i'm not against this i think that being
against this would be to censor you see
though those people why what i do
believe in is free speech in when it's
done in in for not for gratuitously
insulting populations for finding the
truth and and i think that if we're
going to a community like the jewish
community they are sensible enough to
mature enough to be able to conduct free
speech which is not breaking the law not
inciting violence not doing any of this
they're sensible enough and that's why
we have so many allies in that community
if you go on our public platform you
will find so many jewish people holding
hands and placards with us why would
they do that stafford bridge itself i
think i would even wager that the
majority of stanford bridge i don't know
i mean i haven't done a service but
potentially the majority of them
share our types of attitudes towards um
the pro-palestinian course so what what
i think is is that you're saying it runs
a risk of course it does i mean would it
have ran a risk for some uh anti-slavery
advocates in the 19th century to come
out and speak about slavery yes did it
run at risk for them they went into war
in 1861 to 1865 in america for it
did it run a risk for people that aren't
apartheid people against the south
african apartheid for them to be labeled
in certain ways yes but those
individuals who are happy to take that
risk and go forward with it and don't
care about labels especially when
they're being misapplied those are the
ones who make history those who are too
afraid to to do these things they will
meet the dustbin of history the the you
know the trash heap of israel i think i
don't mind uh being labeled and this is
uh i don't mind being labeled as
whatever it is i'm a seaman myself i'm
an arab and vernacularly i'm a see
myself if you want if you want to label
if they want to label me i tell you one
thing label me all you like because you
know why
because
i know it's impossible for a muslim to
be anti-semitic the prophet married a
jew
and in fact not only did he marry an
ethnic jew the prophet muhammad
he married an ethnic jew
but he even armed her with ways in which
she can combat anti-semitic
semitism in her own community telling
her to mention her lineage back to moses
and aaron i think that's a i personally
think that's a bit of a
fluff argument because you can't say
it's impossible for someone to be
anything because quite clearly no no for
a tradition for a traditionalist muslim
has married a jewish woman okay
ethnically jewish yeah and he gave her
arguments for people that were being
abusive to her
to
to combat anti-semitism in her own
community
if i am being a faithful follower of the
prophet muhammad i surely should follow
in his footsteps and that's the kind of
thing i have on my channel if anyone
goes on online now on my channel they'll
find a video entitled why muslims cannot
be antimated or shouldn't be answered
the reason why is because islamically
for following the prophet muhammad he
married a jew himself and he gave her
arguments on how to combat semitism so
i'm not saying it's inconceivable i'm
saying it's it
not to be yeah it shouldn't be yeah it
shouldn't be the case yeah yeah
exactly yeah i can understand that
um can um can i draw a fairly crude
comparison do you think would it would
it in theory
be
offensive for somebody
to
go to a large muslim population part of
london
and
have a
van with pictures of for example the
kabul airport where isis k recently had
you know caused an explosion
and to demand of people that they give
their opinion and outwardly condemn it
would you think that was problematic i
think it's a disanalogous thing because
if we look at the the the studies the
one i've just mentioned to you the
the dr david graham study okay in 2010
which has been conducted by four
thousand jews i think it's one of the
biggest studies and it's been it's been
conducted by the jewish institute policy
industry
this study did say that there was a
sizable number of people
sizeable number of uh jewish people that
support the state of israel and in fact
they base their jewish identity based on
the state of israel the same thing
cannot and ever be
said about muslims and isis you will not
find the level of support are you saying
they feel a connection to israel or they
are supportive of the israeli
government's
actions because those are two different
things no no no not the israeli
government israel as a nation what i'm
saying is now if there are people that
are supportive of israel as a nation and
the government
that is different to isis because it's
not like for like comparison in terms of
the demography there there is there are
simply not as many muslims who support
isis as there are jews who support
israel that's impossible too
if you look at pew for example and see
the kind of um the data they have on how
many muslims support isis and all the
nations including the muslim majority
nations it's not comparable to the
amount of jews that support isis um
israel or the actions of the israeli
government so i think it's a bit of a
disanalogy
but it's it's it's a similar thing in
terms of expecting people
thousands of ways of thousands of miles
away from the actual
conflict itself or issue to answer for
it as if they have no no no once again i
we we're not doing that we went to these
areas
to to get our associates and our allies
from the jewish community to have a
voice
so it wasn't an answer it wasn't
interrogative it was it was more
conciliatory and harmonious we're going
to see our jewish friends in these
jewish areas if there happens to be
pro-zionists who came to us and
challenged us we are ready to debate
them and defeat them in debate as we
have been and the only thing that they
can come back with is labeling us as
anti-semites that is for me an admission
of defeat because that you can't deal
with our argument therefore you have to
label us
so as far as we're concerned okay it's
legitimate even what you've said there
is legitimate if you wanted
uh if bbc or any other news agent
agency came to any area in the world
forget about just london any area in the
world they wanted to ask anyone about
anything i think they should have the
sociological privilege to do so so that
we know what people are thinking what
people are saying i think there's no
it's not an affront to freedom of speech
in fact within the spirit and letter and
the law of freedom of speech and
expression and if we can't do these
things then there is no such thing as
freedom of speech what is freedom it
what it boils down to what then it's a
freedom of speech so long as um
we don't we don't hurt someone else's
feelings you know
then in that case i think people need to
reassess their principles
can i draw back a little bit yeah
do you think
um
islamophobia as an issue is something
that's taken as seriously as
antisemitism as an issue
no
because the government has a working
definition for anti-semitism it does not
have a working definition for
islamophobia
the government the uk government the
conservative uk government
has a
page long definition in fact of what
constitutes anti-semitism of which by
the way there are religious things
because one may make the argument is
disanalogous because they would say that
jewishness is both
ethnic and religious right
whereas islam is is only religious
right but then in the definition where
uh where anti-semitism is the definition
of anthemicism there are religious
components of the religious the
infrastructure the organization so on so
if jewish people are allowed to have a
definition
and a jewish religious jewish people
have a definition which protects them
in the law the muslim people should have
it now obviously it's different because
as i've mentioned when we're talking
about discrimination towards muslim
people it's multi-factual in
sociological analysis if you have a
black muslim
right so they they could be
discriminated against on the basis of
being black
as well as on the basis of being muslim
and these two types of discrimination
are two separate types i'm not saying
one is worse than the other whatever but
it's just a separate type of analysis
and i think when we're doing these
analyses we have to be careful
not to disanalogize um but also be
careful to be consistent because in this
case if there are aspects here
which in the british definition of
anti-semitism are religious surely they
should be
uh separate things for all the religions
not just islam
hinduism
judaism sikhism all of them why do you
think it isn't
given as much i to be to be honest
that's a political question um
are the conservative party concerned
with the muslim community no they don't
see maybe
from from a voting perspective that the
muslim community is going to vote for
them in the first place
so they may not want to
please them as much as maybe they have a
stronger hold in jewish communities in
terms of evolving it might be that
the labor party has has
traditionally had the muslim vote but
now with islam moving in in the
direction that he's moving in
which is uh from our perspective a
anti-muslim direction quite frankly he's
likely to lose the muslim vote himself
so
whatever happens i think that
political parties now need to start
thinking more wisely because we are
according to the census data we are
millions of people in this country we
are millions of people in this country
and if we are not taken seriously then
we'll be
worse and worse things like this unity
will happen and we want to create
harmony in this country with muslims
because we are millions in this country
and i think that the way to do so is to
protect our interests and the more
muslims feel that their interests are
being protected they're less
there there's likely to be
radicalization there's likely to be
disunity there's likely to be a
disharmony there's likely to be all this
kind of thing so i think it is important
that the government come forward with
the definition as they have with
anti-semitism
for islamophobia
how do you think um
we can promote
um a sense of harmony between different
communities specifically with the jewish
community in mind
i think that we really need to just
bring people together if you look at the
pew data okay um and
pure day is very interesting because
it's really seen as the gold standard of
statistical data if you look at the pew
data where discrimination is at its
highest whether it's racial whatever it
may be in different countries you'll
find that it's usually in areas where
people don't mix
you see so a problem for both the muslim
and jewish community has been maybe you
could you could argue a lack of
integration a lack of mixing a lack of
you know having their own kind of
ghettos or whatever it is what we need
to do is we need to bring people
together from different religions let
them play football or something let them
eat together let them talk together and
if there are disagreements between
muslims and jews they should be fleshed
out but they should be fleshed out in a
healthy manner with a with an eye or an
intention to try and create unity and
promote uh civic
coexistence rather than with an eye to
try and create disunity and disharmony i
think if we do that properly
then i think we'll find that this
country will be the beacon of light for
the rest of the countries on and
actually a model on how to deal with the
issue of multiculturalism
are you optimistic do you think that's
the direction the country's going in let
me tell you something i think that they
have there's a lot of reason why we
should be optimistic
in history
and as i say one of my academic
areas of research has been history
convervancy has happened between muslims
and jews in the past the issue has
always been the politics
after 1948 everything has changed but we
can bring it back we can i am optimistic
i'm hopeful we can bring it back
to a situation where we can bring
muslims and jews
back on
civil terms with each other
i'm not saying they're not already on
those terms but on better terms with
each other in this country and i think
if we have the hard discussions
and we allow and we don't label each
other
because people can't fear that i'm going
to speak to my jewish neighbor he's
going to call me an anti-might or vice
versa did you did you fear school being
called an islamophobe but it just
becomes a very toxic relationship no
let's have our discussions
you know and if we don't fear that and
we talk about it then there's a great
hope if we do resort to these kind of
defensive deflective um scapegoating
tactics
then it's going to be
it's got it's going to be
something negative for the community so
yes i am optimistic generally speak
um this is just a broader identity
question yes um
do you in terms of your own beliefs do
you think of yourself as are you
progressive where do you sit in terms of
your
social outlook
i think to be honest with you the word
progressive has overtons or
presuppositions which are really
objectionable actually
because they come from an enlightenment
western enlightenment experience which
is entirely eurocentric
and which has very specific
kind of values in mind
i think
what i consider myself as a
traditionalist muslim that's how i call
myself and i think that in many ways
people not understanding traditions
islam that requ that think that this
type of islam if you like requires some
kind of um
evolution
okay are themselves subscribing to a
discourse
which is in my view actually racial
racial colonial and racial because it's
the same mentality
that
colonizers had before they went into
countries which didn't belong to theirs
and imposed their values
so i object to the term i think
progressive
understood in western language or in in
the west generally speaking has
overtones in there which are entirely
objectionable and not only objectionable
they require to be evidence from first
principle from first principles they are
not argued for thoroughly and they're
just they are assumptions um that are
presented as axioms which we don't need
to accept
um
i'm sorry to bring you back into this
alley i'm sorry
just give me credit
[Laughter]
i think there's a lot of merit to what
you say
but i think specifically that video i
did did strike me as as
problematic in lots of ways and i think
specifically the title of the video
muslims confront radical israelis
was problematic and i don't think
i think it was possibly a shock tactic
headline in order to get more views in
order to promote what is possibly
you want a harmonious yes but do you not
think there's do you not see how that is
problematic there are radical israelis
there's a different way of communicating
what i mean
you're objecting to the term radical
israeli are there such thing as radical
iranians are there such things as
radical koreans but i'm objecting to
radical israelis because
you went to to speak to just some you
know fairly religious jewish people who
are not
you definitely don't know if they're
israelis no no they they they identified
as such and not only that i didn't see a
single person in that video identified
there was more than one israeli there
was more than one video you have to look
at all of them did any of them say yes
she said
they said that we are dual nationalist
israel very much isn't in the video no
that's that video but there's there's a
collection of videos you have to look at
all of them but there's something else
here i want to say that not only did
they do that if you watch the entire
video
when when we talked about why we call
that person radical is because they
totally
um humiliated
children that were being killed
palestinian children and this something
in fact it was they deserved it
or they did it to themselves they did it
to themselves that he said so we we
think someone
who identifies as a jewel nation
a dual nationalist
uh and who who who trivializes the death
of palestinian children says they did it
to themselves it's a radical i think if
that's not radical then we don't know
what radical is one of them said
yeah this is just afghanistan yeah
what's funny
he's walking with his children
there's a little bit of inconsistency
which i'm sure you know there's gonna be
consistency because you can't you can't
i don't know you can't
like like you can't choose who your
followers are you can't there's going to
be nuance in everything but isn't there
inconsistency
um
in
trying to promote a message of
positivity and then maybe focusing in on
only a negative so i think the video
you're referring to is
the gent who what did you say is this
afghanistan
yeah
themselves yeah but is it was that the
majority view you were getting when you
were when you went there and if it were
not are you then not kind of giving an
inconsistently or a disproportionately
large spotlight to something which isn't
representative of how the people you
came across well what i would say is go
and look at our platforms because you'll
find both you'll find we we are
confronting people who are pro zionists
and we are also in hand literally in
hand in hand with people who are jewish
anti-zionist anti-israeli government
actions
advocates so we do both and that's
unfortunately something i have to say
the bbc haven't done enough of um
something that i say that bbc if they
did more of it would be more authentic
journalism i i think the truth of the
matter is what we've done
if we are exposing some bad attitudes in
certain communities whether it's muslim
or or jewish or christian or whatever
kind of community we're talking about
that needs to be exposed
to some extent that does need to be
because how can we fix a problem that we
don't even know exists we need to x-ray
okay we need to put under the proverbial
mri you know
our communities and not just try and
kind of uh white wash or not put onto
the carpet the problems that we may have
in our in our respective communities we
need to deal with them head-on like i
said if it was south african apartheid
if it was a white south african uh
community of
white south africans and there was
apartheid going on
going there and seeing for example some
people agree with apartheid
and then someone come and tell me why
are you broadcasting this i say this is
the problem we need to expose it
see this is the problem we need to
expose it
and i know it can be kind of
uncomfortable for us i know it because i
i'm a muslim okay we see the on the news
all the time we see people doing bad
things in the name of islam all the time
i know it's uncomfortable but it's it's
sometimes um unnecessary
uncomfort and sometimes it's something
we need to we need to deal with because
if we can't if we pretend it doesn't
exist there's no such thing as muslim
terrorism there's no such thing as
racist uh jews there's no such thing as
muslim uh whatever if we think all of
those categories are in fact not even in
existence then we can't fix those things
in our communities i think one second
muhammad you have some a little bit
drops in your
in your flowering your left left eye
left eye's got
is is it shall i clean it or slightly
can you is it
just gonna get worse
has to be good because i'm picking them
up very much with the camera
it might get worse before it gets yeah
we need to we need to maybe just wrap up
guys like soon okay
oh it's getting worse
i'm waterproof
but
can you understand i mean i'm not going
to
um wade into israeli politics and the
issue of israel because it's just so
complicated generally
i've got personal opinions on it all
but
can you understand why for many jewish
people it's very
complicated it's not easy for them to
outright condemn israel can you
understand that perspective but based on
their own sensitivities their own
history can you see why it's complicated
for them yeah i totally sympathize with
um jewish people who have an affinity to
the state of israel i understand that
perspective it's not like a it's an
alien perspective to me
and i empathize with them but i just
think they're wrong on the issues
because when we're looking at right and
wrong right i think all of us agree that
the the indiscriminate killing
of
children
of civilian populations dropping bombs
in a densely populated places gaza which
has been blocked as is there's a
blockade on it okay i think that should
be condemned by anybody from any
religion just like i would be expected
to condemn the actions of whatever
country is that's claims to speak in
behalf of islam iran saudi arabia
wherever i'll condemn any action that
they do even though i have an affinity
to islam and so on i'll condemn any
action that they do in the name of my
religion because in fact
my failure to do so would be a discredit
to the religion itself
that i i think it would be a disservice
to my community and my religion if i
don't condemn those actions and i think
the same thing can be said of
individuals who support the state of
israel who do not condem outright the
actions of a government who drop bombs
indiscriminately in the most densely
populated
area in the world
this is such a broad political question
but um
what resolution would you like to see in
that part of the world what what kind of
what would you like to see happen
this is a very difficult question
whether i what i would like to see
if we need the answers what i would like
to see is co-existence what i would like
to see is what we saw in spain what we'd
like to see is confidential what i would
like to see is tolerance
but what i'm probably going to see is
all the opposite to that unfortunately
right i don't have an optimistic view of
what's going to happen in that area
anyone who looks at the history of that
area will know that there is no
resolution uh that is probably going to
be had in in the foreseeable future i
have to be honest and say all i can do
here is pray
okay guys
the